so tell me how are those new year's
resolutions coming along
today i'm going to share with you a
better way to have your best year in
2022 in just four easy steps for the
last four years or so my husband and i
had a ritual at the end of the year
where we would sit down and reflect over
the past year by writing out an entire
page or pages of things that happen that
we're thankful for and sometimes that
list included even negative things that
actually helped us become better or
learn new lessons and then we would
follow that with creating our goals for
the next year and for us we divided that
into four different categories financial
spiritual social and health but this
year i wanted to try something different
you see what often ends up happening
when we set goals for the new year aka
resolutions is that we often start off
excited and motivated because we have
this fresh start this new beginning but
then the day-to-day challenges of life
just begin to weigh us down and little
by little we either forget about the
goals that we had set for ourselves to
begin with or we start losing that
motivation because we feel like our
goals were just too far too difficult to
achieve and we feel like we're never
really going to be able to accomplish
them or we lose momentum and just don't
take it so seriously as time progresses
because
after all we have the rest of the year
to work on it right
i've recently been inspired by the book
the 12 week work year and i realized
that even though i was always a goal
setter i've been going about it the
wrong way you see when i was a child i
was bullied and i didn't really feel
loved at home and so i felt like if i
achieved something worthy enough or did
something well enough then i would be
worthy of love and so setting goals just
kind of became natural for me and
actually when i was 21 my husband and i
got married i remember telling him that
by the time i was 27 we were gonna have
a paid for house and this and this and
this was how we were going to do it and
in many ways setting long-term goals has
been incredibly helpful but now i see
that i never really set short-term goals
for myself and this
hindered me in many aspects of my life
because i like many of us set these
wonderful goals when the new year began
and then somewhere along the ride they
just ended up shoved in a drawer along
with all my other unobtained goals
sometimes because the goals were just
not specific enough and other times
because they were just too high and
therefore impossible to obtain and other
times just because it was too much work
and i didn't feel like doing it the
12-week work year mentions several key
lessons but for me the biggest takeaway
is that instead of focusing on yearly
benchmarks like my husband and i had
been doing that instead much better
results can be obtained if you shorten
that time span from that of one year to
12 weeks or four quarters when i read
this this became like an aha moment for
me because in business the concept of a
four-quarter year was something that
i've heard of it was something that i
was familiar with but not something that
i had personally implemented in my life
and oddly enough right about the time
when i started to read the book was when
i started a 12-week planner completely
unintentionally it was something that i
actually picked up at a thrift store not
knowing that it was for 12 weeks only
but the benefits that i have noticed in
this first quarter of 12-week goal
planning is that when you have shorter
slots to achieve those goals each week
counts and each day is important and so
it makes you more aware of the fact that
you have only x number of days to
complete this task and it makes you less
likely to procrastinate or abandon ship
and if you actually achieve all of your
12 week goals and then some then you'll
gain motivation as you see your results
in this short amount of time and the
next go-around or the next quarter
you'll start off with even more
motivation even more momentum as you see
the progress that you've already made
and if you do fail and you don't achieve
the things that you had set for yourself
it's okay because guess what having a
horrible quarter does not mean that
you've had a horrible year you still
have another chance to try it again and
so if your results weren't as great as
you had hoped it's okay because you can
have that fresh start that the new year
brings all over again the next 12 weeks
i like to think of it as
four short sprints versus one long
marathon so you're my personal fitness
trainer and you tell me that i need to
run a mile i'd probably say okay i may
get a little short of breath but it's
for a short time i got this
but now if you tell me that i need to
run up a mountain without stopping
that changes things then i'm gonna look
at you like you're crazy that is never
gonna happen why is this it's because
now i'm not looking at this short
attainable goal i'm now looking at this
much longer task that now seems
impossible to obtain and the idea just
became much more daunting and looking
back my husband and i began to implement
the concept of short-term goals kind of
accidentally when we began to build this
house we had some contractor help for
things like foundation and electrical
but we did most of the work ourselves
and i mean we did plumbing completely
from rough to trim we installed flooring
we installed cabinets we installed
windows siding and the point that i'm
trying to make with all of this is that
because we were so physically exhausted
from this long project that seemed like
it had no end at night when we thought
about all the things that we still had
to cross off the list it made us lose
sleep it made us lose motivation it made
us feel like we were never going to
complete it and even if we had made
progress that day it felt like our
efforts were futile and it just kind of
emotionally made us lose that momentum
made us lose that motivation we thought
of the big picture it was highly
discouraging
have you ever given up on a project or a
goal because you felt like you weren't
making any progress if so what was it
let me know in the comments
i remember that when our mindset changed
was when i told my husband let's try
something different let's not focus on
the house being completed as the goal
let's focus on short-term goals and only
focus on those and so the goals began to
look a little bit more like this this
week we will finish rough plumbing and
lay tubs or this week we will finish
laying flooring so by doing this these
tasks now became things that we could
actually visualize as within sight and
so even though the overall goal didn't
change it was still to build the house
our energy was now focused on these
shorter term goals and this completely
changed our perspective because each
goal was something that we could
actually check off the list and feel
like we're making progress we're
actually achieving these things and so
if you've already forgotten about your
new year's resolutions or they're not
quite going like you had hoped it's okay
i want to encourage you to take your own
12-week challenge to do this first set
your overall goals for what you want to
accomplish in 12 weeks you can focus on
one area of your life or you can do like
i like to do and set four different
categories that is for me financial
spiritual social and health for example
if your goal is going to be financial
and you want to get out of debt then
you're going to actually want to pull
out of pen and paper and start to
calculate your income versus expenses so
that you can create a reasonable goal
once you've set your goals then you can
proceed to step two step two is actually
to take these 12-week goals and divide
them up into weekly segments so that you
can have an overview for the week ahead
each week so going back to the house
example you are now going to take your
longer 12-week goals and divide them up
into weekly chunks for example if your
goal was to read more what books will
you read when will you read them how
many chapters a day or each week will
you read
where and when will you read them when
you're going about setting either
long-term or short-term goals it's
important to make them as specific as
possible because this allows your brain
to actually have a plan to follow and a
vision to focus on as you're actually
putting these steps into practice this
will do wonders for helping you stay on
track so make them specific and
realistic because expecting that i'm
going to run a marathon in 12 weeks is
probably not realistic for me once
you've made your specific and realistic
goals it's time for step number three
which is to schedule them i like to do
this by taking some time on sundays to
first of all reflect on the previous
week with some gratitude journaling and
then follow that with planning for the
week to come i like to do this on my
physical planner because it's a one-stop
shop for me i can actually do my
gratitude journaling on it and my weekly
planning but you don't have to do the
journaling part if you don't want to you
can actually do this on a physical
calendar or even google calendar which i
personally love the point is just to
schedule these things so that they
actually get done so that just like you
schedule appointments with friends or
doctors and take them seriously you're
now scheduling appointments with
yourself because you are taking your
priorities seriously and as you go
through the week the last step step
number four would be to have weekly
evals with yourself so look back at the
week prior and ask yourself questions
like did i do as well as i had hoped
what could i have done differently what
did i do well what could i do the next
week to come
really be honest with yourself without
shaming it's not about reprimanding
yourself but rather analyzing how you
could approach it differently if it's
not working out and as you do this week
to week you're certain to learn more
about yourself and what works and what
doesn't work so that you can truly make
this your best year so there you have it
those are my four steps to creating a
better 2022 for yourself so to recap
number one would be to schedule 12-week
goals for yourself number two
two would be to divide them up into
weekly chunks number three would be to
actually schedule them so that they
happen and number four is to have weekly
evals with yourself so hopefully this is
helpful for you let me know if you have
tried out these shorter term goals and
what are you planning to do to make this
your best year i'd love to hear from you
in the comments and hear any suggestions
from you if you've made it this far
please give it a thumbs up and help
support my channel and subscribe so that
you won't miss when i post a new video
thank you so much for watching and i
can't wait to hear from you bye
you